there is a large multinational security  company and their challenge was to  migrate their existing workloads from  there on premise infrastructure in  multiple geographical locations into  Google cloud platform their challenge  was that their applications were very  complex what they've done with cloud  indoor is they're able to remove the  complexity entirely and convert the  systems into a Google platform very very  simply a very lightweight version of  those systems is being maintained in  Google cloud platform and it's only  being spun up when they actually need it  enterprise customers will continue to  use the cloud more and more and the cost  reduction that we've seen among many of  our customers has been upwards of ninety  percent